i was in a village in samoa in the south
pacific
and i don't remember when the rain
started
just that it didn't stop
for more than a a month 24 hours a day
it just kept coming
the rivers rose and soon no one or
nothing could come in or out
we were just there
in the flood
have you or a loved one ever been
affected by flooding
think about it
chances are based on statistics you or
someone you know has been impacted by
flooding
there's a powerless feeling in a flood
you can't stop the rivers from rising
but for the first time we are in a place
where we can shift the power paradigm of
flooding
according to the world water resources
the world resource institute flooding is
the most globally impactful of all
natural disasters
taking between four to five thousand
lives
every year
in the united states
14.7 million properties homes businesses
are at substantial risk of flooding
costing billions in economic losses
every year
in fact in 2010
we spent 176
billion dollars on global flood recovery
which is equivalent to roughly 20 of the
grocery bill for every family in the u.s
for one year and by 2080 were projected
to spend over four trillion dollars on
global flood recovery
wow
that's a lot of money
now i'm talking in terms of groceries
because that's something i can wrap my
head around i know how much i spend on
food
but that money could go to anything
to the national debt healthcare
education back to the citizens you can
do a lot with four trillion dollars
now we're pretty good in knowing just
how bad a flood will be
and we're pretty good at knowing when
they're going to happen
we've been looking to solve flooding
since our earliest civilizations
since noah we've been looking for a
flood workaround
so why is this still such a huge problem
because we love water we need it we
always have to have it we build our
cities next to oceans and rivers because
being next to this critical resource
makes our lives easier
in fact today
most of the world lives in coastal areas
and more and more of the world lives in
urban zones
students and entrepreneurs
seeking bright futures are drawn to
exciting opportunities in cities
in 2008 for the first time half the
world's population was urban
by the time my little girls are my age
more than 70 percent of the world's
population will be urban
that's a rapid growth
and as cities rapidly grow they alter
their landscape resulting in more
stormwater runoff a decrease in water
quality and ultimately
greater impacts due to floods
we seek to allay this through storm
water and flood plain management but in
our dynamic and constantly involving
urban environments the numbers suggest
our traditional approaches
just aren't enough
unfortunately those hurt the worst are
the most vulnerable
low-income unsanctioned housing is often
located in areas of an elevated flood
risk
families and communities without the
ability to prevent and combat
the economic upheaval associated with
flooding are those hurt the worst
and are hurt repetitively
this is a global challenge
and i saw this stranded in the village
of samoa where those same flood waters
destroyed crops flooded markets and shut
down businesses
i took this picture in vanuatu
where this recently washed out bridge
had previously connected communities to
their farms and schools
living in thailand and working in
vietnam and cambodia seasonal urban
flooding made daily activities like
commuting not only a challenge but risky
flood water is not clean
this was reinforced this summer when 63
million people in southeast asia were
affected by floods
i saw this working in afghanistan
where the dry climate is perfect for
flash floods
lack of resilience rapid urban growth
and flood frequency have unfortunately
made afghanistan one of the world's
leaders in deaths per capita
due to flooding
on top of dealing with decades of war
this was reinforced in the spring and
summer of 2020 when thousands lost their
homes and hundreds lost their lives and
flooding in afghanistan
and i saw this working in projects in
kenya sierra leone paraguay haiti
but we see this in our own home towns we
see this in philadelphia when we drive
around after a storm
or when we cross lancaster avenue near
villanova
we've seen this when the mississippi
river floods we've seen this in
hurricanes like harvey katrina and sandy
we saw this this summer in isaiah and we
will see this again
this is a challenge that unites us
and these are challenging times
but they're interesting times
sir isaac newton said if i've seen
further it's because i've stood on the
shoulder of giants
and from the shoulders of giants
we can see the world like we've never
seen it before
this is an image taken by the astronauts
of apollo 17. they were some of the
first to see our whole earth
our beautiful lonely planet had just
been revealed
by 2029
57 000 satellites will orbit our planet
generating hundreds of terabytes of
earth data every single day
we're alive in the data revolution data
is being generated constantly not only
through satellites but gauges and
sensors through our own actions just
using our cell phones
scientists and engineers are learning
how to harness this information to gain
novel insights into how floods work
and illuminate new solutions
sitting here at villanova we can predict
ideal locations for infrastructure in
haiti and kenya and apply artificial
intelligence to know where a river will
cross its banks in utah from our desk
this is being coupled with advancements
in infrastructure
in recent decades engineers have
realized new ways
to harness stormwater
green stormwater infrastructure like the
one shown here mitigates the flood pulse
while cleaning storm water using tools
from the soil and plants
infiltration evaporation and
transpiration
this has been shown to be effective and
efficient in meeting federal water
regulations
and
is surprisingly cost effective too
although this is a fairly new type of
infrastructure it's revolutionizing the
urban landscape
in philadelphia in just 10 years
thousands of green storm water systems
have been implemented
taking the city from being one of the
worst offenders of water quality to a
global leader
and they're not alone similar programs
exist in new york city portland detroit
and many many others
and the success of these programs has
fueled global popularity
but the benefits
aren't just limited to stormwater
but extend to community health and
well-being
environmental restoration and flood
plain management
so these are exciting times these are
times of hope
times that we have the potential to
stand up to the challenge of flooding
and here's the great part
we can all be part of meeting that
challenge
this is an issue of civil infrastructure
and civil infrastructure
is meant to serve civil societies
which includes all of us
it includes everyone
so how does one get involved
number one
use your voice
we need to be investing in solutions
the world resource institute showed that
for every one dollar spent on flood
protection infrastructure in india it
resulted in 248
of avoided damages
similar results were shown in other
countries
if we can invest in mitigation we can
assuage the cost of flood recovery
ultimately reducing the cost of losses
due to flooding
in the united states where much of our
infrastructure is aging it needs to be
replaced or updated but civil
infrastructure is not one size fits all
it has to meet the needs of the
community that it serves
so what are the needs of your community
how's flooding impacted you
speak up let your representatives know
take part in public hearings
and be part of finding the solution for
your community
number two
use your actions
imagine a raindrop falls on your roof
as it rolls over your sidewalk or your
yard what does it take with it
the storm water coming from your home or
your business or your community
impacts the rivers and the streams that
it drains into
so make your property or your community
part of the solution
volunteer to help maintain green storm
water infrastructure or create and
invest in green storm water
infrastructure at your home or your
business
this is an example from villanova
i've circled it in red
because it's not that obvious
this isn't a big obtrusive piece of
infrastructure this is an obtainable
feasible solution
and number three
innovate
stage is set
developments and data computational
power water resource management have
opened the door for advancement
but this isn't just an issue for
engineering this includes all of us
arts education biology chemistry urban
planning public health governance
business all of us
so what's your solution
what's your innovation
what are the next steps
flooding has been an issue that we've
faced since our earliest societies
but for the first time
we have the potential for which we can
find solutions
the damages the costs the lives lost we
can change that
in our yards in our communities in our
cities with our voices and our actions
and our innovations we can find
solutions
and we can shift the power paradigm of
flooding
thank you